On the Border why is the Border more
overwhelmed under your watch Mr
President because there are three
countries that are never having there
are fewer for sure immigrants coming
from Central America and from Mexico
this is a totally different circumstance
what's on my watch now is Venezuela Cuba
and Nicaragua and the ability to send
them back to those States is not
rational you could send them back and
have them while we're working with
Mexico and other countries to see if we
can stop the flow but that's the
difference
uh we don't know what he was saying that
was President Biden on a word salad
attempting to defend this wide open
border of the Southern border as more
than two million migrants have crossed
illegally this fiscal year in numbers
just released by U.S Customs and Border
Protection over 200 000 people were
apprehended at the border just in the
last month with an Untold more That Got
Away upwards of a million gotaways we
are told typically travel first to
Tucson Arizona after Crossing through
Texas immigration has become one of the
top issues in the Arizona governor's
race and in the latest poll Republican
Kerry lake has a nearly five point lead
over Democrat Challenger Katie Hobbs and
joining me right now on this Sunday
morning is Carrie Lake herself Carrie
it's good to see you thanks very much
for being here
good morning Maria I we are very
concerned about the godaway numbers a
million have come in since Joe Biden
took office and these are the most
dangerous ones we don't know what their
background is they could be terrorists
they could be murderous and they're most
likely hardcore criminals well obviously
they have their own intentions they
don't want to get apprehended so they
get away is it true that many of them go
to Tucson are you seeing this in Arizona
they go they go through the Tucson
sector which really is more than half of
our state border and I was just talking
to the sheriff of Cochise County Mark
Daniels and he told me 16
000 are coming through a month in that
sector the Tucson sector just last week
there were two vehicles two of his
Vehicles damaged by Smugglers who
crashed into them trying to get away and
350 people in Cochise County have been
the victims of people passing in
illegally criminals coming in illegally
there have been 350 victims of crimes in
Cochise County in six months alone so it
is impacting arizonans every single day
well I know that this is one of your top
priorities to clean up the Border or
should you win in November I want to
point out what Liz Cheney has said about
you when speaking at this Texas Tribune
uh conference yesterday she says I'm
going to do everything I can to make
sure Carrie Lake Is Not Elected your
reaction
that might be the biggest best gift I've
ever received I mean the people of
Wyoming can't stand her I'm I'm pretty
much sure that the people of Arizona
don't like Liz Cheney uh you know here's
the deal Maria the Republican Party the
new Republican party is the party of We
the People it is no longer the party of
war mongers and so Liz Cheney probably
should change her voter registration
turns out she really is a Democrat after
all well let's talk about your agenda
she said it does include uh campaigning
with the Democrats to make sure that you
don't win uh tell me what your
priorities are in terms of your own
agenda and then I want to get to the
Dobbs ruling uh and and your thoughts on
abortion I know we haven't heard from
you on that subject but go through your
agenda
uh well first and foremost that border
day one we're going to issue a
declaration of invasion call it what it
is and we're going to get troops on the
ground and stop people from coming over
give reinforcements to our border
sheriffs and stop this madness we just
had the largest drug bust in the history
of drug busts in Phoenix Arizona this
week a million fentanyl pills this is a
poisoning of America I don't even call
them drug overdoses because one pill one
half a pill can kill you they are trying
to take down this country all you have
to do is look back in history at the
Opium Wars and see that they brought
down dynasties with drugs and that's
what they're attempting to do we have to
tackle our border we will start that on
day one we're also going to start
working on the workforce issues that we
have by bringing vocational and trade
skill training into our high schools in
a bigger way so that after 10th grade
high school students can get some real
training for the real jobs that are out
there these trade jobs make will allow
kids to make good money where they can
actually support themselves we're going
to bring that into our schools and we're
also going to look at our long-term
water issues as Arizona grows we have to
look at ways to bring water into our
state and so we are laser focused on
some of these big issues that really
impact the people of Arizona care
Carriage lifted that injunction on the
enforcement of the 1973
lateral should prosecute abortion
providers Arizona Has Lifted the
injunction and now the Attorney General
brnovich touts a win for for his office
defending life your your reaction
I'm pro-life I've never backed away from
that and never will I I want to protect
lives and I want to help women you know
we've got to make sure we are giving
women the support they need I'm all for
Health Care for Women the Democrats have
tried to politicize this issue in such a
disturbing way it was just about a week
ago my opponent tried to equate women
who have miscarriages with abortions and
that is really alarming and and Stacy
Abrams saying that the heartbeat is Make
Believe on an ultrasound this is really
sad where they're going with this we
want to help women we want to make sure
that the scary moments when you find out
you're pregnant and it can be scary that
there we are there with them providing
assistance in any way possible but my
opponent is radical when it comes to
abortion she voted against a bill that
would have provided life-saving
treatment to a baby who survived
abortion opting instead to have that
baby die on a cold medical tray that is
radical and the the media here refuses
to ask her questions about her position
on abortion she is for abortion right up
until the minute of birth and even
afterwards and to me that is inhumane
and immoral that is extraordinary I know
that you've been wanting to do a debate
with her she is uh refusing to debate
you do you think you'll get a debate
before the Midtown
no I think she's doing the old basement
Biden play and she's hiding out and
running from reporters I'd love to talk
about all these issues we have major
issues that are facing the people of
Arizona and this state as we go forward
we're about ready to to I believe move
into a realm where we are one of the top
states in the country and there's a lot
of issues I look at this as a job
interview Maria the debate is a job
interview the people of Arizona are the
hiring managers and I'm willing to sit
down and be interviewed she's not we've
actually taken the job interview on the
road we're we're doing five or six more
stops where it's ask me anything and
let's take this job interview on the
road and people are showing up because
they do want to know where each of us
stand on these issues and I'm I'm not
going to shy away from them well it
seems like finally the media is
beginning to cover the Border issues
which of course you've been talking
about from day one and we've been
reporting on from day one I've been to
the Border five times and yet we we see
them upset because of migrants into
places like Martha's Vineyard and
elsewhere I know that you have you have
a thought on on what to do with these
illegal migrants coming in and and what
about sending them to these blue cities
what are your what are your thoughts you
know I'm not I'm not really for that
I'll be honest however it is making a
great point and sometimes you have to
lay things out for these Sanctuary
cities of what we're really dealing with
they lost their minds over 50 illegals
that were sent there and we're dealing
with thousands upon thousands every
month so uh I do think the point has
been made I'm not for moving people
around further into the country makes it
harder for us to move them back across
the border I would ideally like to load
up buses and send them back across the
border we can't take on five million
illegal immigrants and you know if it's
5 million now it's going to be another 5
million the next two years or more we
can't handle that yeah all right we will
be watching thanks very much for being
here this morning Carrie Lake good to
see you hey it's Will Kane click here to
subscribe to the Fox News Channel on
YouTube it's the best way to get our
latest interviews and highlights and
click to subscribe to the will Kane
podcast for full episodes right now